she's dirty she's raunchy
and she's a hit
she's kesha her songs have been taking
the nation by storm but the question is
how much of what we're hearing is kesha
and how much is auto-tune
we stopped by her studio to find out
[Music]
yeah i use a little bit of auto-tune
who doesn't
that's right kesha has admitted that she
does in fact use auto tune
but does it make a difference
[Music]
it's not easy
people expect a certain thing
i actually have to hire a voice double
to crouch behind me and talk for me when
i do interviews you were talking about
the fact that one of your turn-ons is
quarters
and i didn't understand
what how quarters would turn you on and
you're serious about that no i am like i
was doing laundry one day
and i had a lot of laundry and i had a
big bag of quarters and i was just
running my fingers through them and they
were jingling and touching each other
and my fingers what made you decide to
come clean
because my voice is my voice no matter
what it sounds like after autotune is
coming from me
and everybody uses auto-tune pavarotti
bob dylan the beatles they all did it
i'm just pushing the envelope you should
hear the new stuff i'm doing on my new
children's album
[Music]
twinkle twinkle little star and on that
farm he had some horses
[Music]
honestly i think auto-tune is the future
of music
being against auto-tune is like being
against the idea of a dj
it just lets people know you're old